hello and welcome to this video playing
eight miles high while I'm making a fool
of myself that's cut off Stan yes oh and
I'm right okay GM l 0 to 5 18 okay so
we've got a sloth defense and I play
what play I think I go Quincy to the
answer rather reliable line and I've got
some experience with I should really
study the Knight c3 rookie one line this
is a bit more a bit more aggressive but
I never gotten around to do that so I'm
playing this which is not so critical
still I like White's position but it's
not as critical as the other line okay
so maybe just take Bishop do to keep it
simple approach okay I cannot really
move my move my knight yeah that's a bit
awkward because the queen is some is
unprotected hmm ok maybe shoot for g for
him
hmm it doesn't my dad yeah maybe maybe
it's not a big deal see txt for i also
have roped e4 which is the double attack
ok ok so I'm going to push them back now
here ok so I have 95 is one move it's
not so bad right gaining some space in
the process I wonder maybe I should have
known taking you for first and probably
would have would have made a big
difference ok this is just this is just
fine sorry no problem at all so maybe
kingi 44 f 4
okay so what now hmm maybe a FOIA make
it a bit more difficult for him to
expand them okay so well he have a good
couple of moves I can even do this
my more active King position and answer
the space is it's just in my favor here
I don't think I can be vers en this
position would be somewhat surprising
check rather the opposite I think he has
a hard time to keep it on okay so i can
maybe hear rookie to on now i can takes
you far that's better for white the
question is if he goes back to c8 if I
can play something better okay
irrelevant I guess decided to just be
clearly worse okay so i can do look on
the seven droop before mmm Roxy seven
checking the five rook a 4mm it's not
it's not decisive
threatening this hour I'm not sure about
this maybe just keep the material I mean
Kingda 76 still should be quite quite
good jack check Jerry this wasn't the
strongest it's very much possible ok
King d6 you will check me now maybe that
wasn't as strong as possible check check
check yeah the question is king c6 if
this is enough to to do anything
substantial
yeah okay i can check take just seven
probably check answers right trying to
win the edge point as well now look at
should win actually a [ __ ] and to where i
go to be seven he has rook here work on
the fourth okay it's not so convincing i
have a five but i don't think that
should work okay that was a good to move
check time morning check check
check check check John I probably have
to agree to draw him okay it's
disappointing but I'm running running a
one-time draw our third game draw yeah I
should win this game but I couldn't
really figure it out I think somewhere
here it should be very close check check
check this i think probably correct
check and check and maybe around here
check I look a 7 is stronger hmm I
decided on that really quickly now
probably this is really strong guy with
this hangs and if he does that yeah I
will I will win this pawn yeah that
probably wins with the airport look age
too let's see what this is some color to
play
check check here's a draw it's not it's
not probably not snot forced or anything
it's probably better than what I did
yeah I probably say Jack no check I
wasn't sure what this till they close to
the end yeah maybe this is better than
him this is better of course him check
here at least I keep the two pawns even
though check the a pond here is pretty
quick had not sure I could still be it
wrong yeah maybe I could have done
something better here okay b3 is a lot
stronger now that wins a clear pond oh
okay check so that was better than 95
yeah i tok this is what this was also
possible I wasn't sure about this here
shakes me and I wasn't sure how to
continue here e 6 is given by the
computer yeah i saw that movement well I
saw that position but I wasn't I wasn't
positive that this is good because I
don't promote the eporner I cannot play
for me tea always has has checks on the
from the back this may be yeah it's
probably good for why but I couldn't I
couldn't couldn't figure that out okay
thanks for watching